shameless has never been afraid to
highlight the debaucherous and at times
depressing exploits of the Gallagher's
and the man behind the most arranged
moments of all as a family patriarch
William H Macy's Frank sure Frank was
drunk and strung out on pain meds when
he had sex with his teenage neighbor
Karen Jackson
who also happens to be his son's
girlfriend and the daughter of Frank's
love interest but if being under the
influence was an excuse for doing bad
things Frank Gallagher's soul would be
as pure as driven snow
yes Karen takes advantage of him yes
Frank has no idea Karen is filming the
act as payback for her father's cruel
words but it's fair to assume that any
man with half a brain cell or half a
soul would stop the sexual encounter
right away instead
Frank is a willing participant one of
Frank's hallmark qualities as his encana
knack at taking a bad situation and
making it so much worse such as the case
in the second season premiere when Frank
nearly loses his youngest in a bet
overhearing a drug dealer claiming he
withstood two Taser blasts Frank bets
money he doesn't have that the dealer is
lying
unfortunately for Frank with the help of
the bartender's taser the dealer proves
he can ride the lightning
[Music]
Frank's only idea for making the money
it's a panhandle or using his toddler
son Liam to garner sympathy
unfortunately that means Liam is with
Frank when the drug dealers crap him off
the streets since Frank has nothing else
to give them the dealers take Liam as
collateral
Frank callously shrugs off losing his
son in a bet and doesn't even inform the
other Gallagher's what has happened
until they confront him that terrible
decision-making lack of responsibility
and disregard his family's safety or
reflect classic Frank parenting every
man has his limits but Frank Gallagher
that limits is incest barely in
shameless is fourth season Frank Luntz a
punishment he's been putting his liver
through that left him with only a short
time to live you know you're dying right
we're all dying doc too desperate to
find a potential liver donor Frank
reveals that he has another child that
the family is unaware of a
illegitimate daughter named Sammy that
he lost contact with before any of the
other kids were born he tracked Sammy
down and finds her living in a trailer
park with a child of her own rather than
attempting to connect with his daughter
Frank romances her hoping it will help
him to convince her to agree to donate
part of her liver
the to almost sleep together but for
once Frank actually avoids sex
Frank's plan Tomas works messin with her
manipulative father Sammy does exactly
what Frank once and offers to be a liver
donor but once Frank learned she isn't a
match he unintentionally reveals sisters
honesty in a frustrated runt what your
daughter once again Frank's brazen
disregard for other people hurt someone
unlucky enough to be related to him when
Frank finds out that dotty aka
butterface
is slowly dying while awaiting a heart
transplant he goes about swimming her in
an attempt to secure her government
pension that alone is pretty despicable
her Frank's next moves become his new
low point one day Dottie is taking a
shower and the phone rings the hospital
has found the matching donor meaning
Dottie could receive her life-saving
transplants early she would have her
Frank nut lied to the caller by telling
them that Dottie had already passed this
disgusting and incredibly self-centered
act is a death sentence for Dottie later
though he knows Dottie's weakened heart
can't handle it he agrees to have sex
with her dartie dies before it's over
where most people see a terminally ill
child Frank sees an opportunity after a
local news report highlights a cancer
stricken child who has granted his wish
to meet the Chicago Bulls Frank's
devious wheels begin to turn this time
it's Kyle's turn to get caught up in one
a French lies as the preteen is
convinced by his father that he has
cancer Frank even goes so far as has
shaved the boy's head faming it will
help the son's healing rays get in well
the scam does not score the sports
memorabilia Frank was after it does get
coal sent to a special summer camp for
terminally ill children
cole complains a lot about the comes
lack of a shooting range or ice cream
sprinkles though he does use his
presumed illness to con a camp counselor
in a way that would make his dad proud
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos buy
your favorite stuff our coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the Bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]